So
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal an
ob das besser geworden ist seit dem
Early Access, nein Schwachsinn was erzähl ich denn
seit dem, wie nannte
sich das, seit dem Playtest und jetzt im
Early Access, oh
Gerade Bestellung für den neuen PC rausgeschickt
Excellent
Ja, Battlebit braucht mindestens nur 40
90, sonst geht da gar nix
Obviously
Geht da gar nix sonst
Das wär echt
ein echtes Game was von ein bisschen Raytracing
oder so profitieren würde
Ach 6,5, oh ja das stimmt
Also ich hab meinen nach ziemlich genauen
5 Jahren erneuert
Davor einen
8700K 1080Ti
und jetzt einen
13900K mit 4090Ti
Äh, ohne Ti, StreichTi
Also zum jeweiligen
Zeitpunkt eigentlich
in beiden Fällen, so mit das
Nonplusultra
Nur dass der diesmal viel viel
teurer war als der letzte
Gut, lag aber auch daran
Weil ich die 1080Ti
nicht selbst bezahlen musste
Hätte ich da mal selbst bezahlen müssen, wär's auch
teurer gewesen, aber damals war insgesamt
Grafikkarten noch nicht so teuer
Damals hast du nur 1000 Euro
für ne Grafikkarte ausgegeben und nicht
50.000 Euro
Wie viel hast du davon von der Steuer absetzen können?
Ja gut, das war letztes Jahr
Ich hab die Steuer noch für letztes Jahr nicht gemacht
Aber wahrscheinlich nichts
Verbotlich
Vielleicht ein paar Teile davon
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwas als
Ich muss mich mal meinen Steuerberater fragen
Keine Ahnung
Ja gut, Kassenwasserkühlung ist easy, mal ganz viel
Kohle weg
Ich hab nur so ne 0,15 Standard Wasserkühlung
Aber auf der anderen Seite
Die kühlt ja auch nicht schlecht
Nicht schlechter dadurch
Magst vielleicht noch ein paar Grad mehr
Rausholen, ja
Aber meine Grafikkarte ist ja auch nicht
Wassergekühlt, nur meine CPU ist
Wassergekühlt, meine Grafikkarte hat ganz normale
Luftkühlung
Was aber auch nicht schlecht ist, dann ist ein bisschen
Airflow in dem ganzen Gehäuse
Ich hab ja vorne zwei Lüfter
Wenn ich das jetzt so richtig vermute
Hab ich vorne Lüfter?
Nee, hab ich nicht
Unten
Unten hab ich glaub ich Lüfter
Ach, keine Ahnung
Bleib kühl genug
Ja, so einfach ist das nicht
Nee, nee, nee, so einfach
Ich hab nicht nur
Du kannst nicht alles, einfach nur
Weil du Gewerbe hast, instant absetzen
Du hast keine gute Erfahrung gemacht mit den All-in-One-Dingern
Ja
Gut, ich mein
Bis jetzt tut gut
Allerdings ist es ja auch erst ein halbes Jahr alt
Bisschen mehr
Leider macht EVG ja keine Grafikkarten mehr
Ich glaube sogar meine 1080Ti
Könnte sogar von EVGA gewesen sein
Hat EVGA nicht
Damals die offizielle
Nvidia
1080Ti gemacht
Die
Wie nannte sich das?
Das Founders-Modell
Glaub schon
Die war echt nice
Hat der Bauer nicht
Letztens ein Video gemacht, wo er bei EVGA vor Ort war
Oder vielleicht war sie
Ich hab's nicht geguckt, ich hab nur das Thumbnail gesehen
Und die Überschrift
Ich dachte, etwas in der Richtung
War da
Ja, heute
Werden wir uns der Frage widmen
Dass der Battlefield-Killer ist
Oder nicht
Allerdings, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung
Es gibt keine Battlefield-Killer oder keine größeren Battlefield-Killer
Als DICE selber
Ich bin irgendwie noch nicht so richtig
Eingespielt, nicht so richtig fit
Ich werde gleich ein paar Runden spielen
Das ist flutscht
Und ich hoffe ja, dass ich das ein oder andere
Gameplay-Material zusammenkriege
Im Zweifelsfall schneide ich halt ein paar
Rundliche Clips zusammen
Dass ich mich bei einem Youtube-Video dazu auslassen kann
Weil, ich mein, ich hab zwar noch nicht großartig
Early Access gespielt, ich hab vorher ein paar Runden gespielt
Power ist gut, eine Runde hab ich vorher gespielt
Und
Ich hab aber halt
Die Playtests gespielt
Das ist mir jetzt schon aufgefallen, ich hab das Gefühl
Man sieht die Objectives
Jetzt besser als noch im Playtest
Und ein paar Sachen
Wirken auch nicht mehr so hakelig
Aber viel hat sich nicht geändert
Also ich bin mal gespannt, vielleicht entdecke ich ja noch ein paar Sachen
Ah ja, es hat jetzt bessere Onscreen-Hilfe
Zahlst du weniger Jobs
Zahlst du weniger
Ich weiß es nicht, wahrscheinlich
Das macht alles mein Steuerberater
Ich hab keinen Bock, mich damit auseinanderzusetzen
Aber ich hab
Ich hab sogar relativ viel
Obwohl ich eingenommen hab, mit Youtube zusätzlich
Hab ich sogar noch immer Geld zurückgekriegt
Die letzten Jahre über
Außer letztes Jahr
Letztes Jahr musste ich, also deswegen muss ich dieses Jahr
Wieder nice Geld überweisen
Geh vorgestern gekauft, 8,5 Stunden
Oh, das ist tatsächlich ordentlich
In 2042
Gibt's gerade Rush XL mit
64 vs 64
Auf den gleichen Maps
Mit den gleichen M-Comps
Das kann ja nicht funktionieren
Nicht direkt, aber was ähnliches
Ja, die gleichen Maps
Ja, ok
So, dann würde ich sagen
Calculate
Schauen wir uns das Ganze mal an
Ich bin gespannt
Oh Gott, Anti-Cheat-Shit, Alter
Geh mal nicht auf den Sack
Ja
Muss man auch noch Root-Passwort eingeben für den Mist
Ich fass es nicht
Hast du die Playtests?
Ja, fast alle
Nicht alle, aber fast alle
Schon vorüber
Ich hab doch damals ein Video zugemacht
Vor zwei Jahren oder so
Also schon
Die ersten paar Playtests
Ok, Menü-Musik und so
Gibt's nicht, gibt's immer noch nicht
So, lasst mal kurz in die Settings gucken
Wir müssen unbedingt
VoIP
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich VoIP anlassen soll
Leute
Wenn ich VoIP anlasse
Könnte es sein, dass irgendwie einer
Absoluter Bullshit erzählt, was auf Twitch problematisch ist
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist VoIP
Immer auch relativ lustig in dem Game
Ich lass es mal an, mal gucken
Wenn sie es total übertreiben, muss ich halt VoIP ausmachen
Wir können vielleicht das VoIP-Volume
Ein bisschen runterstellen
So
Und wir müssen, bevor wir anfangen
Mal kurz in die Shooting-Range
Und alles ausrüsten
Ich glaub, ich hab vorhin schon so konfiguriert
Wie ich's haben will, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich alles erwischt hab
Weil in der Runde hat man ja nicht sonderlich viel Zeit
Lass mal die Battlefield-Soundtrack laufen
Der passt doch eigentlich ganz gut
Ok, Charakter
Also, was ich gesehen hab, was ich schon relativ nice finde
Und da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher
Das hab ich mir in den ganzen Playtests nie so richtig angeguckt
Was ich ganz nice finde
Die Ausrüstung hier ist nicht
Rein Kosmetik
Ein paar Sachen haben auch einen Sinn
Zum Beispiel kann man den Back
Fällt mir ein
Wisst ihr, was mein Opa jetzt gesagt hätte
Der hat so einen Standardspruch gehabt
Der hat mich immer übelst getriggert und genervt
Ich hab ja gerade gesagt
Das ist ja nicht nur Kosmetik
Das hat schon einen Sinn
Und daraufhin hat mein Opa gesagt
Und wenn's ein Blödsinn ist
Und da fand er sich immer übertrieben lustig
Und das ging mir so auf den Keks
Das hat er zu fast jedem
Zu jedem Ding gesagt
Ja, richtig
Cringe
So, zumindest
Das ist ja nicht alles nur Kosmetik
Und manche Sachen finde ich echt cool
Nämlich zum Beispiel
Dass die Backpacks
Aktuell, also Standardbackpack
Also Rucksack
Ermöglicht zwei Primary Gadgets und ein Secondary Gadget
Und wenn ich den Rucksack
Austausche
Ach guck mal, es gibt ja auch welche
Da kann man weniger Gadgets haben
Aber ein bisschen mehr Running Speed
Oder aber es gibt auch welche
Die, ähm
Bring ich das durcheinander?
Ich dachte es gibt auch welche, da kriegt man ein Secondary Gadget mehr
Ist Battle Build wirklich so nice wie angepriesen?
Ja, das schauen wir uns jetzt gleich an
Ne, ich will eins
Der einen Secondary Gadget mehr gibt
Aber dann hab ich mich verguckt
Es gibt ja halt ein bisschen mehr Aim Speed
Ein bisschen mehr Running Speed
Versus, du kannst kein Secondary Gadget mitnehmen
Und kein Primary Gadget
Was bedeutet
Man kann
Zum Beispiel
Ah, hier muss ich noch umstellen
Man kann keinen Smoke-Granatwerfer mitnehmen
Und man kann kein
Moment, das ist nicht der Medic, den ich ausgewählt hab
Das ist der Assault, wollte ich grad sagen
So, jetzt nochmal
Backpack, geht das vielleicht beim
Ja, guck hier
Da ging das
Du kannst das umstellen
Dann kriegst du hier was
Also zwei Secondary Gadgets
Und sowas mitnehmen
Und man sieht, es fällt mir jetzt auch erst auf
Die Dinger sind sogar unterschiedlich zwischen
Medic und dem Assault
Eigentlich ganz nice gemacht
Gehst du noch täglich wandern?
Ja, bei heute nicht
Sonntag ist meistens so der Tag, wo wenn ich nicht gehe
Dann ist es meistens Sonntags
Ja, mach ich
So, und Secondary
Primary ist logischerweise die Waffen
Was doch tatsächlich gar
Keine allzu miese Auswahl ist
Ja, ich mein mal
Ganz im Ernst, Rang 106
Und sonst was, bis ich das hab, ist halt
Keckweight
Man kann übrigens alles nehmen
Also man kann als Medic
Nicht nur eine UMP nehmen, sondern auch beispielsweise
M4A1
Und die M4A1 kann man auch noch
Hier customizen
Mit zig Dingern
Das ist sehr simpel gemacht, muss man sagen
Find ich gut
Extended Mag
Quick
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich nicht vielleicht das Extended Mag reinpacken soll
Mehr Schuss
Was ist denn das? 30 Schuss
Versus 45
Und dafür hat er
Vertical Control
Probieren wir mal
Probieren wir mal mit Extended Mag
Main Sight, Red Dot, Chordra
Chordra Visier, Leute
Zweites, nee, das brauchen wir nicht
Camouflage
Top Secret
Weapon
Das sieht gar nicht mal so mies aus
Guck mal
Man kann das, guck mal Prestige
Prestige Unlocks gibt's noch
Und das alles ohne
Pay to Win
Was nehmen wir denn hier?
Sowas da
In Blau
Sieht eigentlich gar nicht übel aus
Was hat man dazu bieten?
Side Rail
Laser
Nee, das suckt, das brauchen wir nicht
Barrel
Basic
Aha
Gibt's Suppressor
Vertical Recoil
Okay, Vertical Recoil geht halt übelst hoch
Mit Suppressor
Suppressor Short
Ah, okay, da hat man weniger
Sound, wobei es gibt ja eh keinen
So richtiges
Spotting, oder?
Also ist das erstmal nicht so wild
Under Barrel
Warum hast du das alles
Unlocked?
Weil das, glaube ich, die Startwaffe ist
Und es hat auch keine Level und sowas
Guck mal, was kann man hier?
Angeled Crib
Nee, Angled, nicht Angeled
Control
Tickle
Das ist wirklich so
Best of die letzten paar Battlefields
Sozusammen
First Shot Kick, ja, das ist vielleicht echt
Nicht schlecht, wenn das ein bisschen runter geht
Aim Down Time
Running
Okay, Running Speed suckt halt, wenn das
Ich lass jetzt einfach mal
Kurz Default, gucken wir uns das dann an
Ja
Die anderen Sachen habe ich nicht
Unlocked
Vielleicht ist es auch, weil es die Firing Range ist
Das kann auch sein
Aber es sah jetzt nicht so aus, als hat es nur bestimmte Level
Ja, und
Was wollte ich jetzt noch
Irgendwas wollte ich doch noch zeigen
Achso, ja, bei den
Hups, bei den Gadgets
Hat man als
Medic, gut, man kann Pistole und so Gedöns mitnehmen
Aber aktuell
Habe ich halt bloß
Ein Kill, yeah
Habe ich halt noch nie
Da hast du einen First Aid Bandage
Das ist ein Unterschied übrigens, ein Unterschied zwischen
Medipack und First Aid
First Aid ist, dass du aufhörst zu bluten
Medic
Kit ist zum heilen
So, und dann nehme ich den Smoke Launcher mit
Und an der Stelle
Die
Frag Granate
Alles klar
Disconnect
Yes
Dann schauen wir mal, vielleicht
Ist auch gar nicht alles unlocked
Das checken wir jetzt gleich mal, Multiplayer, Quick Match
Ich mache mal 64 wie in 64
Ich glaube 128 ist auch in dem Game
Zu chaotisch
Battlefield Soundtrack aus
Wir müssen mal kurz Lautstärke check machen
Da Windows ist man
Da nie so sicher
Ah, die Map kenne ich
Die habe ich glaube ich im
Nicht Early Access, halt im
Pre-Early Access
256 ist zu viel Chaos
Oh, nice, wir haben gewonnen, easy
Sehr gut, Top Map
Wir spielen, keine Ahnung, Domination
Ich sag das jetzt einfach mal
Lenovo
Übrigens, ist denn dann ein
Achter Squad in Battle Bit ein Battle Bite?
Okay, ich gebe zu
Das war schlecht
Not like this
Okay, Loadout
First Aid Prime
Ja, here come, ah, ich kann den Smoke Launcher
nicht auswählen, sucked, Alter
Ich habe nur diese hässliche Mine
Secondary Gadget
Throwables, aber da nehmen wir eine Frag
Granat, Granate
Ja, okay
Vielleicht wäre so ein
Smoke gar nicht verkehrt
So, Loadouts
M4
Okay, man hat wirklich einfach
schlicht und ergreifend hier alles unlocked, null
Aber Leute, ich will das
Ich will das
Codera Visier
Das habe ich in Battlefield 3 schon immer gespielt
Aber 50 Kills sollten wir
ja relativ schnell unlocken
Ich fahre mal mit
Ich fahre mal mit irgend so einem
Oh nee, F ist es zum Einsteigen
Alter
Ich würde gerne einsteigen, wenn das möglich ist
Gibt es nicht
Ja, Minimap gibt es auch nicht, dafür gibt es halt eine große Map
Das dumme ist, man kann sich nicht bewegen
richtig, also mit der Maus
Ich habe immer so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, mich da auf der Map
im Eifer des Gefechts zu finden
Passt schon
Sind die Maps ein bisschen detailreicher geworden
oder ist das eine der neuen Maps
Ich glaube, das ist doch nicht die, die ich kenne
Oh, diese Magazin-Geschichte
ist immer noch das gleiche
Du hast hier Magazine, es macht übrigens auch
total Sinn, dass du Magazine hast
wenn man weiß, dass
und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das stimmt, aber das hat mir
morgen einer im Stream erzählt
dass die Entwickler
von Battlebit
der eine Spiel viel Battlefield
und der andere, oh, Revolution
Leute
Massive Revolution, der eine Spiel viel Battlefield
und der andere Spiel viel Squad
Was einige Sachen
schon
so ein bisschen
erklärt, ja, zum Beispiel auch
dieses Magazin-System und sowas
Da kann ich im Leben
den kann ich im Leben von hier nicht bashen
Au
So, heil ich mich mal kurz selbst
Oh, oh, oh, oh
Gehst du mal fort
What the fuck
Oh, dachte, hier kann man rüber
Achtung, Achtung
Hi
Ich kann nicht retzen, okay, warum nicht
Wahrscheinlich, weil
er schon released hat
Mit R werfst du hier schon das Magazin weg
Äh, okay
Aber
Aber warum
Was ist der Sinn von Magazin
wegwerfen
Hat man dann irgendwie schneller reloaded, oder
Ach, der steckt das
nicht ein, der wirft das einfach
nur weg
Das ist cool
Sind wir hier eigentlich gerade auf C
Oh, ich bin gerade auf C
Da sind doch bestimmt Gegner, oder
Oh, oh, oh, shit
Ich, Bandage, Bandage
Bandage, Bandage, Bandage
Ich bleib hier einfach dahinter stehen und heil mich jetzt ganz
frech selbst, in der Hoffnung, der sieht mich nicht
Hab ich eigentlich nochmal ein Extended Mag
Hehehehe
Gebashed
Ich hab absolut
nicht den leisten Schimmer
von wo mich gerade was gekillt hat, eventuell
der Panzer
Ja, unten rechts sieht man ihn, das weiß ich
dass man unten rechts immer Magazin sieht
Ich hab mich nur gefragt, was der Unterschied ist
zwischen wegwerfen, oh, hier, Achtung
Oh, der Pantsman
ist am Start
Vielleicht sollten wir mal reinspawnen
als Engineer und gucken, ob wir was gegen den
Panzer machen können
Mal gucken, wie gut das Standardlayout
ist
Äh, wo
Okay, RPG
am Start
RPG
Map, wo sind wir, okay
Wir sind, äh, da ist C
Okay, Orientierungsschwierigkeiten
Das ist doch nicht die Map, die ich kenne
Was ist denn das für ne, ah, ne
MP
Okay, das war zwar im Kopf, aber
das hat nicht gereicht, wir gehen jetzt mal
hier rüber und versuchen den zu
bashen, falls der nicht schon
deadge ist
Der ist bestimmt schon deadge, deadge?
Nicht dead? Ja
Ist er down? Oh, da drüben, da drüben
Gegenüber, gegenüber sind sie
Jetzt probieren wir mal was
Hahaha
Ja, Kollege
Kurz reloaden
Nope
RPG on inf
Mal kurz
auf die Map gucken, wo hier überhaupt was geht
Okay, Richtung, wir müssen
War da was?
Nee, oder? Wir müssen Richtung C
Ein Problem gibt's immer noch, ich seh die Objectives
nicht, wenn man hier guckt
Das ist bestimmt ein Feature, dass man die nicht sieht
Aber ein verwirrendes Feature
Gefährlich hier so
über die Map zu rennen, quer über die
Straße
Komm, wir haben C gecaptured
Die Legehenne war am Start
Wir haben alle M-Comps, Leute, guckt euch das an
Nee, A haben wir nicht, A ist da unten
Resupply
Äh
Jetzt bin ich überfordert
Ich hab nicht genug Punkte, oder?
Doch, doch, doch, die Magazine sind voll
Gibt's sowas wie Rush als Modus?
Mh, glaube nicht
Wow
Okay, ich
revive den jetzt
Wo auch immer
Ich da gerade wen revive, aber nice
Ich hab Cops revived
Yep, yep, Cops
In your face
Oh, gegenüber, gegenüber, Leute, Achtung
Hehehe
Lulve
Oh, oh, oh, gegenüber, gegenüber
Nach, Alter
Shit
Nee, Rush, Rush gab's glaube ich
nicht
Ich glaube, hier gibt's kein revive
War eine Frage
Unabhängig von welcher Bank könnt ihr für ein Giro-Konto
und so empfehlen?
Äh
Also ich hab ein Konto bei der 1822, weil
das rein online ist und man sich da um
nichts kümmern muss
Ob ich das jetzt so prinzipiell empfehlen würde?
Weiß ich nicht
Aber wo sind wir hier
überhaupt?
Richtung A? Richtung C?
Moment, die capturen C
Wir müssen C defenden
C
Defenge
Oh, was ist hier los?
Wow, wow, wow
Leg dich hin, ah, shit, shit
Was ist hinlegen?
Okay
Z ist hinlegen, Alter, Moment
Oh, Moment, Keybindings
Keybindings
Das kannst du ja vergessen
Äh, wo ist es denn?
Crouch
Ach, Z, ernsthaft, Z
Hat er jetzt Teamchat
unbindet von Y?
Nein, natürlich nicht
Geil, was? F1 to clear
Wer braucht schon Teamchat?
Lul
Ich hab's schon umgestellt gerade
Vielleicht können wir da
Vielleicht können wir da reinspornen
Das wäre extrem
Ogg
Guck mal, der macht doch gar nichts
Der ist überhaupt nicht
Lügt nicht, Game, der ist nicht in Combat
Okay
Der ist einfach geplatzt
Ich hab null Orientierung gerade
Okay, das ist die richtige Richtung
C, C, da geht's lang, alles klar
Wir versuchen jetzt mal
den Pantsman zu killen
Wir haben doch immerhin hier
Oh shit
What the? Ach, das war der Heli
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was hat der hier für einen krassen Turnon gemacht
Wo ist denn das?
Ne, das ist
Ich hab so ein bisschen Schiss irgendwie
Ich versuch mal hier rüber zu kommen
In der Hoffnung, kann man hier einsteigen?
Enter
Oh, wie lange dauert das in das Auto zu gehen?
Guck mal
Drei Stunden
Und jetzt bin ich Gunner?
Ne, was bin ich denn?
Ich bin
Ich weiß es nicht
Ich bin Spotter oder sowas
Observe
Dangerping
Hä?
Ich bin Spotter oder sowas in der Richtung
Ne, das suckt
Ich will kein Spotter sein
Kriegt ihr auf YouTube in letzter Zeit auch so sinnlose Videos empfohlen?
Harry Spotter
Und solche Dinge
Leute, der Pantsman
Jawoll
Nice
Hab ich gerade den Panzer in die Luft gesprengt?
Plus irgendwie so ein Typ daneben
Exzellent
Ich hab noch nie Engineer gespielt
Trotzdem ganz
Trotzdem den Early
Daytests
Let's checken
B, C, wir sind richtig
Stellst du uns mal rüber zu C?
Da rennen ganz viele von uns rum, pushen Richtung A
Da pushen wir jetzt mal mit
Alter
Ich seh in dem Game teilweise nicht wo die Gegner sind
Wir switchen jetzt wieder von Engineer rüber
Zu Medic
Und man muss sich an eine Sache gewöhnen
Da hab ich immer die ersten paar Runden Probleme
Das Game ist halt einfach
Viel langsamer als Battlefield
Wenn man
Wenn man zu stark reinpusht, so wie eben ist man halt
Mehr oder weniger instant
Instant dead
Und am besten ist
Eigentlich ist es auch besser durch Häuser zu laufen
Hier oben so durchs
Guck, guck, guck
Ich weiß nicht von wo, aber ich werd schon wieder von allen Seiten abgeknallt
Kann ich
Oh ich hör was
Oh fuck
Da freut er sich
Ich hätte nicht drüber klettern sollen
Richtung C
Es gibt Rush? Wirklich?
Das müssen wir gleich spielen Leute
Rush ist prinzipiell immer
Bester Spielmodus
Nach der Runde erinnert mich dran Leute
Wir müssen Rush spielen
Wenn es Rush gibt ist Rush immer
Besser Modus
Sag mal
Hab ich das
Ist über mir jemand
Jetzt ist halt die Frage
Die Häuser sind zu wir aufgebaut
Kein Plan wo hier was ist
Aber irgendwo ist hier was
Über mir
Fuck Alter
Wo ist denn
Ja Kollege damit hast du nicht gerechnet
Erstmal
Den Panik
No
God
Ich weiß schon was mir in dem Game auf den Sack gehen wird
Claymore Shit
Alter
Komm wir fahren mal ne Runde mit Tank
Oh ne
Wieder Spotter
Oder F3
Ja das war ne Claymore
Ey kein Bock auf spotten
Richtung C
Wir können
Wir werden halt easy
Von der Seite weggestellt hier
Das
Wenn da einer war sind doch
Bestimmt noch mehr hier
Meiner? Okay
Zum Glück gibt es kein Friendly Fire
Ist das ein Spawnpunkt
Ich glaub das ist so ne Art Spawnbeacon
Die sind aber hart drauf
Okay wir
Schleichen wir stellen uns ein bisschen von der Seite an
Ist halt auch
Alles sehr vertikal hier
Kann immer einer hocken in irgendeine Ecke
Wir sollten mal
Ein bisschen Richtung C
Aber vielleicht
Oh Shit
Einer erwischt
Claymore mitten auf der Wiese
Okay ich merk schon das dauert ein bisschen
Bis man da reinkommt
Es ist halt komplett anders
Vom Feeling her als Battlefield
Zwei Stück
Mal gucken an der Seite
Shit
Okay pass mal auf
Wenn das klappt bin ich als Cheater
Gewandt
Oh was geht denn da
Nicht releasen man ich wollte dich retzen
Dead
Guck mal man muss ein bisschen campen in dem Game
Dann geht das
Voll im Kopf
Ich hör hier drüben
Nur noch was oder
Leute
Ah vom Dach
Wir waren hier
Irgendwo
Nicht in Combat sein
Nicht in Combat sein Leute
Out of Combat sein ist besser
Out of Combat
Größer in Combat
Richtung C
Wo ist C
B A C
Man sieht die Dinger übel schlecht
Die M-Coms
Ich bin da regelmäßig verwirrt wo die Dinger sind
War das ein Schneider
War das ein Schneiderscope was gerade in meine Richtung geguckt hat
Wow
Ich revive den
Nein mach ich nicht
Mach ich doch
Kann ich den sogar heilen
Pog Medic
Hey stehenbleiben
Healge
Ich glaube übrigens man hat unendlich Heal
Charges im Medipack
Wie komm ich denn da
Wie komm ich denn da runter
Vielleicht ist runter
Gar keine so clevere Idee
Ich mein Highground ist
Wie in Overwatch
Beste
Ich kann irgendjemand revive und ich weiß nicht wo
Aber
Okay
Habt ihr gecheckt wo ich den Typ revived hab
Dead
Bip
Ist der Typ hier hingekommen
Ist der hier hochgeklettert die ganze Zeit
Pog Woib ja
Richtiges Teamplay hier am Start
Ich sollte mich
Übrigens mal selbst heilen
Was mit linker Maustaste geht
Was im Early Access
Ihr wisst was ich meine
Dieses Pre Early Access Ding
Oh da drüben
Ich will da rüber
Ich will die beschen
Die sind eindeutig da oben
Okay ich mach einfach
Kamikaze
Aber man sieht schon
Es ist deutlich taktischer
Als es Battlefield 2042 ist
Vielleicht Chat wenn ihr wollt
Wir können nochmal zum Schluss eine halbe Stunde
In Rush XXL reingucken
Wobei das bestimmt
Massive Cringe ist
128 Player Rush auf diesen Kack Maps
Da drüben war was
Ich hab Angst rüber zu gehen dann bin ich dead
Okay Achtung Achtung
No
Boah
Das ist einfach hinter mir
Mal ein komplett gegnerisches Team
Ich hätte vielleicht nicht aus dem Fenster springen sollen
Da hätte ich jetzt 12 Leute killen können
Es war einfach das komplette Squad
Es war nicht nur das komplette es war das ganze Gegner Team
Wo wo wo
Ich glaube wir gewinnen
Wo ist denn die Ticket Anzeige
Ja ja
Die mit den vielen Kills sind wahrscheinlich
Irgendwelche Heli Stelz Typen wieder
Da war was oder
Leute hab ich da was gesehen gerade
Oder
Ich glaube ich bin einfach blind
Da war wahrscheinlich
Sniper
Ich glaube im Haus sind aber welche
Ja
Gehen wir da mal hin
Achtung hinter meinem Tank lang in der Hoffnung
Ich snipe keiner
Also das Gefühl mit das du beschossen wirst
Haben sie ganz gut hingekriegt
Was ist hier los
In irgendwie einem der Fenster
Das geht mir in dem Game
Das ist halt auch so ein Punkt der mir im ganz
Im Early Access schon auf den Sack ging
Du weißt halt einfach oftmals nicht von wo
Vielleicht sollten wir auch erstmal
Wir stellen es uns jetzt mal
In eines der Häuser hier wieder rein
Wie pingt man eigentlich
Wo ist es nicht
Da guck mal da sind sie schon
Oh shit da ist noch einer ich muss weg
Wow das war close
Die konnte ich nicht contesten
Shit alter immer da wo man nicht hinguckt
Mittlere
Ah mittlere Maustaste ist ping
Gut zu wissen
Okay nicht damage take
Nicht damage take
Oh da ist was runter gesprungen gerade
Was willst du hier machen
Das ist zu viel
Okay safe spawn
Nicht zu viel Battlefield in your face rushen
Sondern ordentlich an der Seite spawn
Okay nice
Hier bei dem zum Beispiel
Nee der ist jetzt dead bei dem spawn war
Und jetzt müssen wir in welche Richtung
What the
Fuck
Ich heal so mich mal
Ich weiß nicht von wo
Oh
Ich muss mal kurz verstecken
Hier sind doch garantiert noch mehr
Das Haus hier ist doch
Bestimmt
Voll
Ich hab bisschen schiss
Hier raus zu gehen weil es könnten durchaus noch welche
Drin sein
Sag ich doch
Ich bin schnell verpisst der dude
Aber leben tut er noch
What the
Was zum
Hä
Wait what
Wollte er mich snipen gerade von hinten oder was
Kann man nicht hoch
Okay wir müssen
C ist da
Was man halt nicht sieht
Ich glaube wir haben gewonnen
Easy haben wir gewonnen
Eats
Max hast du eigentlich
Weiter Sport gemacht ja mach ich jeden Tag
Sonntag ist ein bisschen wenig aber ja jeden Tag
Du hast doch mal irgendwann ein Video
Zu gemacht
Ne Gewicht ist ungefähr gleich
Weil ich fresse übertrieben
Wieder
Aber Gewicht bleibt gleich
Weil ich mich ordentlich bewege
Machst du dann Sport
Ich bewege mich einfach eineinhalb Stunden am Tag
Durch die Landschaft
Hier in der Nähe
Ein bisschen bergrunter
Aber es ist weder dass ich jetzt
Krass renne, Fahrrad fahre oder sonst was
Ich bewege mich einfach eineinhalb Stunden
Ich laufe recht zackig eineinhalb Stunden
Manchmal sogar zwei Stunden
Hier durch die
Durch die Berge in der Nähe
Ist anstrengend genug
Dass man genug Kalorien verliert
Und nicht zunimmt
So Rush wo gibt es denn Rush überhaupt
Server Browser
Rush
Game Mode Rush
Ist aber alles schon voll
Hier Rush
Ja Cola ist eh
Es hat einfach keine Textur
Die Map
Gibt einfach keine Textur
Texture not found
Nee aber Cola ist echt der Teufel
So was das angeht
Ist das jetzt immer noch Rush
Ich hoffe dass das immer noch ist
Die Map wird gebaked
Ich muss die Karte durchhalten
An welchem Ziel bist du dann angelangt
Wie viel hast du
Synchronizing
Ich glaube das Game ist gerade gecrashed
Ja
Crash gibt
Server Browser
Rush
Ja
Rush haben wir irgendwie noch ein bisschen Platz
Refresh
Geh weg
Rush
Jawoll
Hab in 18 Monaten 62 Kilo
Alter
Das ist ja heftig
62 Kilo
Da kann ich ja mit meinen
Wie viel sind es denn jetzt
17 Kilo oder so
Instant verloren
Danke für den Sub
Ist es wieder Rush
Ich hoffe jetzt funktioniert das Join vom Server
Connected
Perfekt
Rush
Jawoll und wir sind auch
Attacker vermute ich mal
Wir haben neues Loadout
Oh cool
Primary
Ne
Codra Visier
Am Start
Endlich
Pocket Champ
Loadout
Magazin haben wir noch nicht
Das ist ein bisschen
Unbearable
Den will ich nicht
Mal kurz die Musik ausmachen
Okay
Let's go
Codra Visier is back
Endlich
Das ist 1 zu 1
Was willst du machen
Rush
Ich hab den nicht erkannt
Vor lauter Tarnung
Für mich
Ich hab nur die Waffe gesehen
Die sich bewegt hat
Oh da war was
Bandage
Jawoll jetzt wird er noch gehealt
Ja
Oh da hinten läuft ein Gegner
Rush
Let's go
Ich muss den Mapflow irgendwie checken
Wir müssen wahrscheinlich einfach nur
Mittlere Maustaste ist pink
Mal gucken ob die Maps
In irgendeiner Art und Weise
Brauchbar für Rush ausgelegt sind
Sieht bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so aus
Die Regeneffekte
Gefallen mir
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Minecraft
Was ist denn hier los
Okay die Maps sind nicht für Rush
Ausgelegt
Das ist irgendwie ziemlich pp gar gerade
Moment
Okay
Also
Rush ist
Merkwürdig
Ich versuch mal rein zu spawnen
Falls es geht
Ich spawn bei dir rein
Vielleicht ist es auch nicht so wild
Wir gehen mal rüber zu B
Sichtbarkeit im Wall
Monarch Estheim
Pingen wir das mal
Rush
Die sehen mich schon auf 3km hier ran rennen
Ich bin gleich dead
Okay nice
Durchs Dach
Hock
Okay schnell
Rush durchs Fenster
Ich lass euch mal vor
Ich hör nämlich von links was
Hier ist doch definitiv was
Oh
What the fuck
Ich dachte wenigstens der erste ist tot
Schnell spawnen
Jawoll
A
Wo ist B?
Wo ist die Legehenne?
Wir haben Legehenne am Start
M-Comp
Auf M-Comp
Please explode
Explode
Alter explodiert das heute nochmal
Wie lange brauchen das
3 Jahre
Au
Das braucht ja ewig
Das M-Comp ist ja
3 Stunden
Die kriegen das bestimmt noch diffuse gleich
Komm schnell ran hier
Schnell
Wo ist B?
Auf Suche
Habt ihr es gehört?
Typisches russisches
Geflame am Start
Ich hab absolut kein
Blassen Schimmer was hier abgeht
Die wissen das ich da bin
Also
Die Rush Spielbarkeit ist
Komisch
Das spielt sich
Das spielt sich alles
Ich mein das sind 64
Doch 64 Spieler
Und alles halt auf mega engem Raum
Aber mal gucken
Ich heal jetzt erstmal seinen Poppes
Okay nice
Ich glaub wir müssen das ein bisschen umlaufen
Ich glaub so dieses frontal
Okay andere Maps sind besser
Ich glaub so dieses frontal ran
Ist wirklich nicht gut
Wo sind wir denn hier auf der Map
Hier dürfte jetzt eigentlich keiner sein
Von den Gegners
So mal kurz selbst heilen
Ich glaube nicht das hier einer herkommt
Die sind bestimmt zu faul
Aber die wissen das ich da bin
Oh fuck der ist schon tot
Da drüben
Sie kommen
Ich hätt nicht reloaden sollen
Sie sind unterwegs
Da ist noch einer
Der Typ bei uns ist gleich dead
Ne los
Mit sowas verarschst du mich nicht
Dafür spiel ich so Games schon zu lang
Luca was machst du da
Ich brauch ein volles Magazin
Okay und jetzt müssen wir ran hier
Stellst du uns mal kurz hier hinten
Durch die Gegner
Hä von da
Okay
Samuel
Jetzt am Start
Moment ich bin mal nett
Da steht zwar das ich ihn heile
Aber ich heile nur
Ach wir haben gewonnen oder verloren
Wir haben verloren wahrscheinlich oder
Jetzt sind wir Defender
Okay das finde ich gut
Das es eine Runde hin und eine Rückrunde gibt
Das finde ich gut
Loadout
New
Wann gibt es denn den
Oh Rang 55
Das dauert ja ewig
Bis ich Rang 55 bin
Was bin ich denn jetzt für ein Rang
12 naja okay
Aber es geht bestimmt langsamer
Nein es gibt keine HP Anzeige
Du hast aber so eine
Art HP Anzeige
Du hast so eine Art HP Anzeige
Wenn du Medic bist und dich selbst heilst
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin ob das nach
HPs geht oder ob das
Generell einfach so eine Cooldown Anzeige
Ist
Okay
Was
Okay jetzt könnt ihr sehen wie wir die Map verlieren
Dude
Geh da nicht rein
Also ich weiß nicht
Komische also komische Map
Was willst du da machen
Ich kann es ja nicht beim reinlaufen
Komplett jeden einzelnen Winkel
Also eine Sache sieht man aber da
Man muss schnell sein für Rush
Das es was wird
Und man hat ewig
Zeit zu diffusen
Obwohl das 64 Spieler ist
Und ziemlich kleiner Raum
Dafür braucht man noch eine Weile bis man da ist
Also es wirkt
Zumindest als hat sich einer Gedanken drum gemacht
Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz ob sich das
Wirklich gut spielt also das fühlt sich nicht
An der Stelle fühlt sich
Also hier auf der Map gerade nicht so gut an
What the
Ich kann es komplett knicken
Hier gerade
Nein ah
Ich hab einfach eine Mine gelegt
Falscher Knopf
Sind wir dead
Oder haben wir diffused
Ja wir haben diffused gemacht
Diffused
Lohnt sich das Game
Schwer zu sagen
Äh
Ne
Hä
Das Rush ist
Nur eine Base
Rush ist eher sowas wie
Ähm
Demolition oder sowas
Ok
Also da fehlt noch einiges
Um das zu einem gescheiten Modus zu machen
Ok lasst uns mal eine Map
Lenovo
Lenovo bei Nacht
Gucken was gewinnt
Beim Angriff habt ihr es nicht
Weiter gepackt bei Defense geht es dann nur
So weit wie die andere Seite ist
Ah das ist die Overwatch 2CP
Taktik
Ok das ist nicht schlecht
Wenn das so ist
Scheint nicht übel zu sein
Schauen wir mal
Oh ist mein Game gerade gecrashed
Crashge
Ok dann ist es doch
Durchdacht jetzt sind wir Defense
Lenovo Thinkpad
Ja
Guck das ist die Foxconn Fabrik
Hier
Wo kommen die denn eigentlich her
Ok richtige Richtung
Text 4
Texture not found
Leute ich hab ein Problem
Ich muss weg
Zum Glück hat er mich erst nicht gesehen
Das war deutlich schneller
Feinkontakt als ich das
Antizipiert habe
Die Anzeige
Vom UI ist echt so ein bisschen verwirrend
Weil wo ist denn
Der Gegnerspawn in die Richtung
Ja schon
Ok wir sind wieder
Bei der Foxconn Fabrik
Da können wir in der Mitte nicht
Nicht durch da müssen wir außen rum
Oh shit
Ist ja alles voll
Ok jetzt hab ich ein Problem
Ok wir müssen
Leute
Nice
Vielleicht haben wir Glück
Wir gehen jetzt nicht mehr rein
Oh nein
Können wir uns hier irgendwie durchstelzen
Von der Seite
Alter
Minimalismus
Bis zur Unkenntlichkeit
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen
Ich war von Anfang an kein Fan von diesem Grafikstil
Also ich habe nichts gegen Pixel Grafik
Das wisst ihr
Aber
Dem Spiel fehlt einfach Beleuchtung
Ah shit
Ich glaube sowas wie Raytracing
Oder so wäre halt mega dafür
Weil es auch nicht viel Leistung
Frisst also das Game an sich
Nicht viel Leistung frisst
Ich habe keine Orientierung auf den Maps
Ist das die Lenovo Fabrik
Nee die Foxconn Fabrik hier
Alles klar
Vielleicht hab ich Glück
Nice guter Spawn
Äh wo ist B
Exzellente Sichtbarkeit
Aber es fehlt einfach Tiefe
Das sieht so
Manches hat ja Texturen
Aber vieles ist einfach nur einfarbiger Block
Also ich hoffe
Da oben war noch ein Gegner oder
Irgendwie noch
Noch ein bisschen was machen wir
An den Grafiks
Ist hier einer drin
Hier ist doch einer drin oder
What
What the
Da kann man durchspringen
Und warum guckt der in die Richtung
Überhaupt
Ich sollte nicht
So viel Dauerfeuerabenteuer
Sprühen und beten hier
Können wir Diffuseke machen
F
Alter
Das dauert ja 3 Stunden bis man hier
Diffused hat
Okay komm
Jetzt gehen wir mal außenrum ein bisschen
Hier ist alles besetzt
Von unseren Leuten
Gehen wir mal rüber zu A
Nee machen wir nicht
Die sind im Haus hier drin
Das sind meine Dudes
Die Map ist weird
Mal gucken wie wir uns auf Attacker
Schlagen
Haben die jetzt gelegt
Nein nein
Falsches
Ja ist klar
Das siehst du gell
Ich will da überhaupt nicht rein
Springen
Da war doch einer
Nice
Hypersichtbarkeit
Habt ihr den gesehen
Das ist 1995
Nach der Runde muss ich mal kurz
Mit der Katz was machen
Erinnert mich mal please dran
Alter
Ich weiß nicht
Anscheinend gewinnen wir
Ist dein Thinkpad zu oft abgestürzt
Nice Joke
Chico jetzt nicht
Ich muss Diffuseke machen
Wir müssen ein bisschen außenrum laufen
Das funktioniert doch sonst gar nicht
Ich hab halt null Plan wo überhaupt
Gegner sind
Hier ist alles voll oder
Okay nice
Moment die sind an A oder
Die sind im Haus
Wo gehts denn hier in das Haus rein
Hier
Sag mal
Haben die geplantet
Legehenne
Okay
Alter wie viel
Bonkers
Okay erzähl mir was passiert
Wenn die
Chico jetzt nicht
Erzähl mir was passiert wenn die
A einnehmen
Destroyed okay
Chico ich mach dir die Tür
Ah shit
Mensch
Was hast du jetzt gemacht
Chico
Jetzt hat sie was runtergeschmissen
Weil sie nicht schnell genug gegangen ist
Wie ich die Tür aufgemacht hab
Die hat jetzt
Einfach was runtergeschmissen
Weil sie nicht schnell ging wie ich die Tür aufgemacht hab
Nice
Kein Wasser und so
Aber das ist immer so geil
Die sitzt einfach 30 Sekunden
Vor der Tür und ich reagier nicht
Sofort was wird gemacht
Irgendwas runtergeschmissen
Das geht nicht schnell genug
Wo bin ich eigentlich
Und wo ist der Gegner
Ich bin
Vierter
Ich bin vierter mit 15
Zehn
Massive
Also es geht anscheinend
Anscheinend allen so
Wir spielen ja da wieder ein bisschen
Von Rush bin ich irgendwie noch nicht so richtig
Überzeugt
Vielleicht muss man das aber auch ein paar mal gespielt haben
Dass man so den Fluss halbwegs
Checkt
Wo kommen die überhaupt her
Hier aus der Richtung
Dahinten quasi
Das heißt
Wir gehen jetzt mal
Wir gehen jetzt mal hier außen rum
Und versuchen
Da irgendwas abzustelzen von der Seite
Okay
Ich werde schon gesniped
Nice danke
Ich werde schon versucht
Wegzusnipen vom Dach
Den auf dem Dach könnte ich mal draufballern
Wenn der sich wieder zeigt
Macht er aber nicht
What
Game please
Bist du Battlefield 2042 oder was
Einfach komplett durch
Okay
Ich heile den
Ich weiß nicht von wo
Oh was ist das da
Alter switch auf die Waffe
Oh shit
Zu lahm
Doch die Attacker haben es gerade
Erwischt hier bei uns
Aber ich habe den
Fluss der Map noch so gar nicht raus
Ich heile euch nochmal
Ich heile euch auch nochmal
Ich gebe wenigstens Punkte
Okay wo ist hier was
Wo ist hier was
Moment Moment
Die haben Legehennen gemacht
Ich weiß nicht wie ich Rush spielen soll
Das ist die letzte Rush Runde
Weil sonst habe ich keinen Bock mehr
Das habe ich eigentlich jetzt auch keinen Bock drauf
Dass ich keinen Bock mehr habe
Oh ein Häuschen
Nice Camper Posi
Perfekt aber wir müssen Diffuse machen
Oh wir haben Diffuse
Hat man den Melee Angriff irgendwie
Oder kriegt man das hier nicht kaputt
Wahrscheinlich kriegt man das nicht kaputt
Ich heile dich
Oh der lebt nicht mehr
Exzellente Sichtbarkeit
Hä
Irgendwas hat mich gesniped
B
Okay ich meine komm B sollten wir doch wenigstens halten
Ich camp mich da jetzt irgendwie mal an die Seite
Von B
Oh was sind das
Sehr sinnige Röhre
Hä
Ich weiß in dem Game einfach nicht
Wie ich gekillt werde
Was ist das
Ein schöner Release
Neue Runde
Ich glaube es geht los
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn
So Leute ich muss mal kurz zur Katze raus
Und muss dir was verabreichen
Und dann spielen wir eine ordentliche Runde
Mein Conquest und das Anfangen war mega nice
Aber Rush ne ich weiß nicht
Also entweder muss man sich da noch dran gewöhnen
Oder es ist irgendwie
Äußerst wir
Was ich an Rush mag ist dass es klare Linien gibt
Wo was herkommt
Mit ein paar Flanks
Aber das war überhaupt nicht der Fall
Null Plan gehabt wo was ist
Bin gleich wieder da
So wieder da das ging tatsächlich schneller als gedacht
Wir spielen jetzt Quickmatch
64 vs 64 easy
Overhyped
Bisschen vielleicht was aber auch daran liegt
Dass 2042 so beschissen war
Ich glaube ich muss
Ich muss Rush noch ein paar mal in Ruhe
Lass mir das angucken
Bevor ich jetzt irgendwie erzähle
Das ist einfach nur Kacke
Weil
Vielleicht kommt es auch ein bisschen damit
Wenn du die Maps kennst und weißt wo du hingucken musst
Aber es war schon äußerst wir
Du hast echt keine Ahnung gehabt
Das ist tatsächlich bei diesem Flaggen einnehmen
Irgendwie sogar noch klarer
Ähh Domination
Ich wähle einfach mal irgendwas
Small Maps
Capture the Flag
Ich bin in den letzten Tagen nicht overhyped
Overwatch ist nicht mehr overhyped
Ist auch das erste was mir eingefallen ist
Das hatte niemand so richtig
Also
Gerade nachdem die den PvE Modus gestrichen haben
Oh das ist eine neue Map
Die kenne ich noch nicht
Auch wieder sehr spärlich texturiert
Let's go
Hier sind wir
Select the spawnpoint
Hier in der Base
Moment
Let's go
Wo müssen wir hin
Ganz falsche Richtung
Komplett falsche Richtung
Das läuft auf kompletten Toaster
Das ist richtig
Vielleicht hätte ich mal zu ein paar Autos
Rennen sollen
Anstatt hier den
Über die halbe Map
Sprintstelz anzutreten
Übrigens die Idee
Dass man mit Autos nicht instant einsteigen kann
Ist gar nicht so blöd
Weil
Dann kann man nicht dieses
Ich renne auf die Straße hoppe ins Fahrzeug
Und so machen und dann wieder raus
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht
Das Spiel laggt
Okay das
Soll das
Warte mal soll das Wasser sein
Ich glaube das soll Wasser sein
Das habe ich schon vor Youtube gesagt
So drei Stunden später sind wir da
Ich höre einen Panzer
Als ist der neben mir
Der ist tatsächlich neben mir
Ich komm lass mich gunnern
Kann man nicht irgendwas den Leuten zurufen
So lass mich einsteigen
Bisschen was wie spotten geht
Spotting
Spotting light
Okay wir haben B
Eingenommen
Aber in B ist bestimmt gerade echt die Hölle
Los weil ungefähr die
Jetzt zum gleichen Zeitpunkt
Trifft hier auch das andere Team drauf
Guck ja
Man sieht es von da drüben
Oh nice danke
Von wo
Es war doch nirgends wo war es
Das habe ich auch schon
Bei den early play test immer nicht gecheckt
Manchmal von wo man gekillt
Wird
Komplett wir
Ich hätte dich gerätst
Wollst du nicht okay
Wow
Nice nice danke
Lass mich leben please
Okay volle Pulle
Meiner
Nice
GG
Die leben doch noch oder
Dachte ich mir
Wie viel habe ich noch in meiner
Das check ich noch nicht so ganz
Oh was ist das hier
Caps lock
Was zum
Ah da kann man das abschneiden
Das ist nicht gut
Das ist nicht schlecht
Da siehst du
Irgendwelche Squad
Leute sind wenn man auf solche Details
Achtet
Übrigens das Ding
Finde ich auch viel angenehmer als diesen komischen
Webster
Ah shit von hinten
Webster Grappling Hook
Das ist halt ein Seil was am Dach hängt
Wo du dann hochklettern kannst wo die anderen auch hochklettern können
Und nicht dieses komische Ding
Wie in BF2042
Alter
What the fuck ist denn hier gerade
Unter mir los
Ich habe ein bisschen Schiss ehrlich gesagt
Weil es hier so viel knallt
Um mich drum herum
Da hinten ist doch was oder
Markus
Jawoll Markus ich rette dich
Ich weiß nicht wo du bist aber
Ich heile mal Markus
Ich heile einfach mal mein Team
Ich weiß zwar nicht was hier abgeht aber
Schadet nichts
Ich sollte hier weg
Leute ich sollte hier weg
Okay revive
Oh oh shit
Aber
Von wo wahrscheinlich vom Haus gegenüber
An B ist die Hölle los
Oh shit
Ist da
Okay ich hole euch
Ich hole euch
Oh da oben ist ein Gegner
Ich seh ihn
Da oben
Okay volle Pulle
Vielleicht habe ich Glück
Ah erwischt
Also an B
Ist ja mal richtig
Wow
Alter an B ist was los
Da ist die Hölle los gerade
Alter
Du hast ja keine ruhige Sekunde hier
Oh der war gut
Der war nice
Achtung ich heile dich mal
Von der Seite
Hier ist gerade richtig was los
Wunderbar
Hab ich die Community jetzt aktuell
Ja aber du hast hier auch
Richtig nervige Leute
Shit shit shit da ist ein Gegner
Und ich hab keine Muni drin
Okay
Der ist weg
Ich bin mir unschuldig wo soll ich hin
Ins Haus
Ins Haus ist immer gut
Da war einer
Hier draußen
Kommt gleich was rein
Komm mal hier
Ich renn nicht rüber Leute
Den Fehler mach ich nicht
Sobald ich
Hier stürzt gerade ein Haus ein
Wenn ich hier rüber renn bin
Ich heile mich mal selbst
Oh shit hoffentlich kommt hier keine Granate rein
Ich dachte den kann man so killen
Okay vielleicht
Vielleicht
No
Alter
Ey das Game macht mich gerade
Shit
Alter das war
Ich werde gerätst
Nein dead
Der hat nur drauf gewartet
Guck mal hier alter Boomer
Top Squad
So muss das sein
Ja man kann Leute wegziehen aber ich hatte überhaupt keine Zeit
Irgendwas zu machen
Wo bin ich denn überhaupt gespawnt
Okay
Wir können hier nicht raus
Wir sind dead wenn wir raus gehen
Okay der wird jetzt gerätst und ich kann ins Haus rüber
Hoffe ich einfach mal
Fuck
Da lag noch einer in der Ecke
Und es ist besser als 2042
Kann man so pauschal nicht sagen
Wie
Die werden recht schnell gebannt
Sag bloß das ist ein Spielehersteller der guckt
Und auf Reports achtet und Leute bannt
Das kann ich mir das glaube ich erst wenn ich es sehe
Wunderbar texturierte Müllcontainer
Texturierte Müllcontainer
Das haut ja deinen Scope links und rechts
Du kannst ja nix mehr treffen
Wenn du gerätst
Oh oh
Ich muss ins Haus
What the actual
Fuck ey
Das ist doch hier nicht normal
Ich bin fast dead
Wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt auch dead
Weil die mich gleich hier flanken
Ich kriech jetzt einfach nur noch hier lang
Bisschen Camper
Camper Gameplay
Okay
Haben wir es? Sind die dead?
Tatsächlich?
Oh Pantsman hat mich gesehen
Ich muss weg
Komm her
Da ist er
Okay Game das war kein Hit
Ach der war schon tot
Der ist schon dead
So gehen wir mal hier raus
Vielleicht da
Oh
Extrem
Oh Mist
Ja nice Kopf
Nur Kopf raus geguckt
Mal gucken ob der wieder
Shit
Ich wollte mir gerade die Levolution angucken
Wie das Dach
Habt ihr gesehen wie das Dach weggeflogen ist
Nice
Ne jetzt wieder
Jawohl
Oh
Ähm
Wo bin ich denn überhaupt gerade
Irgendwo Richtung
B wieder
Oh oh oh
Man muss wirklich ordentlich vorhalten
Dass das funktioniert
Ist da was auf dem Dach?
So wo geht denn hier jetzt was
Hier geht ja anscheinend nichts
Oder heißt das B blinkt
Dass Gegner noch in Range sind
Wir fahren mal Buggy
Start the
Engine
Sind wir hier in Arma oder wo gelandet
Ich verpiss mich mal
Ich wurde gerade ein bisschen
Die sitzen einfach random in dem Haus drin
Nice du kannst mich retzen
Ja
Nice
So
Der ist full health
So geht hier was
Achtung A
Achtung
Die Granate
Die geht gut
Huge
Auf mich schießt
Einer mit Raketen gerade
Alles dead
Ich bleib mal kurz hier liegen
Da sind Gegner links um die Ecke
Wo ist der Rest
What the
Ein Minipack ist schon OP oder
Ich heile dich auch noch
Ja der ist voll
Full heal
So ein bisschen spotting
Ich hab echt keinen Plan
In welche Richtung ich gucken soll
Außer dass wir hier etwas
Unglücklich glaube ich
Oh den kann ich heilen
Ich mag die Anzeige
Dass man sieht genau was
Also man hat
Not
Not richtig sicher
Was mich da
Hypergutscheat hat aber
Dafür sind wir ja medic
Ok Richtung B müssen wir
Vor allem müssen wir raus hier
Müssen raus
Und zwar verstecken
Vier verstecken wir uns jetzt
Bestes Versteck überhaupt
Und jetzt sollten wir zurück Richtung B
Weil während ich hier mein komisches
Rumgestelze gemacht hab
Haben die B eingenommen
Ich glaube generell kann man
Eigentlich kann man glaube ich die ganze Runde
An B bleiben
Ne man hat nur Healspa für Leute die man heilt
Und sich selbst wenn man sich heilt
Wobei ich beim Selbstheilen nicht ganz sicher bin
Ob das irgendwie ein Cooldown ist oder
Oh nein
Ja
Der hat doch im falschen Moment gepikt
Ok gehen wir an B rein
Full attack
Auf B
Spawnen Spawnen Spawnen
Heile ich schon
Geil gerade nochmal
Ruhe es
Wir sind in die falsche Richtung
Wir müssen da hin
Wir sind verkehrt
Hier gehts lang
Ok kein Hit
Oder war das ein Friendly
Ich kann hier nicht stehen bleiben
Ich bin dead wenn ich hier stehen bleibe
Gehen wir kurz wieder ins Haus
Vielleicht kommen wir hier raus
Ok
Vielleicht können wir hier außen rum flanken
Weil ich hab so ein bisschen
Schiss
Noch ist hier halbwegs safe
Komm her aber nicht lange
Hallo ich möchte dich rätseln
Ich höre Gegner draußen rumhüpfen
Also der Sound ist ganz gut
Ich weiß nicht warum
Call of Duty
Irgendwie verlernt hat
Footsteps in Games reinzubringen
Aber sogar die bekommen das halbwegs hin
Ok wir müssen weg
Ich versuch mal
Sprint
Knapp
Schlechte Idee hier hoch zu rennen
Wie kommen wir jetzt am besten zu B
Wie kommen wir hier am besten rüber
So
Irgendwas hittet mich
Oder versucht mich zu hitten
Keine Ahnung von wo
Hier in dem Haus
Keine Ahnung
Ich geh mal kurz aufs Dach
Oder was auch immer
Oh nice pose
Da camp ich mal kurz
Da kommen bestimmt Gegner gleich
Ich hör sie doch schon
Unter mir
Ich hab sie unter mir schon rennen gehört
Anzeige ist raus
Warum ist der einfach nicht sichtbar
L0
Erwischt
In your face die Granate
Wie viele Tickets noch
Dauert noch ein bisschen
Kann man sich hier raus trauen
Ja komm wir trauen uns raus
Der Pantsman
Kommt von der Seite
Warum
Sag mal warum schießt hier jemand hin
Kann man doch nicht erzählen
Ok deswegen
Deswegen
Das waren meine Leute die dahin geschossen haben
Oh ich hör was
Ich hör was
Ey das war meiner
Pass mal auf wir machen jetzt Sound Horing
Wie in CoD 4
Wir stelzen uns hier lang
Aber da ist nichts mehr
Vielleicht haben wir Glück
Was ist denn das
Einer von mir
Ich kann irgendwas holen
Jaja ist gut
Komm her
Das finde ich cool
Die Leute heilen sich hier ordentlich gegenseitig
Da drüben ist was
Ok
YOLO
Schlechte Idee hier hin zu gehen
Ok
Ich brauche jetzt mal
Evolution Effects hier
Ich brauche jetzt mal ein bisschen Action
Wir probieren jetzt was
Ok volle Pulle
Rüber hier rüber
Dead
Hier sind bestimmt noch mehr
Wow wow wow
Help me
Jaja ist gut
Oh
Ich weiß nicht von wo
Oh shit
Vielleicht hab ich Glück und irgendein Medic ist am Start
Drüben liegt da der Sack
Der Sack
Wir sind dead
Wir sind so dead
Ich respawn einfach
Nein du darfst nicht in Combat sein
Nicht nicht in Combat sein
Bester Graben
Exzellenter Graben da waren wir eben schon mal
Dann sind wir
Darum
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnern kann
Ja ich glaub schon
Und jetzt
Hallo ok
Wo sind wir
Oh fuck
Da war noch einer
Gibt es ein TDM Modus
Es gibt Infantry Conquest
Oder sowas
Das ist glaube ich nur
Nice Game
Hab überhaupt nicht gelaggt der Typ gerade
Oh oh oh
Langsam
Wiederbelebungs
Oh
Heilen
Wallah
Oh hier sind aber ganz schön viele
Wie ist die Dichte an Aimbot
Man kann das schwer beurteilen
Weil man immer nicht sieht wer einen gekillt hat
Das ist halt bisschen
Bisschen problematisch
Manchmal denke ich auch
Alter wie haben die mich gesehen
Aber oh shit
Jetzt müssen wir hier Power Medic machen
Jawoll
Oh da ist ein Heli
Direkt über uns
Ich glaub mehr heilen kann ich jetzt
An der Stelle echt nicht
Die haben genug Cheater
Du brauchst nicht erst Cheater
Dass du über Anti-Cheat nachdenken solltest
In einem Multiplayer Game
Ich kann doch nicht mal meinen Kopf hier hoch machen
Ohne dass ich Dead Kimm
Ey ich hätte dich retten können
So gehts dir
Sobald du deinen Kopf hier hoch machst bist du dead
Guck hier seht ihr das
Wie soll ich denn hier wegkommen
Ich hab noch nicht mal eine Smoke Granate
Wir probieren jetzt einfach mal wieder ins Haus zu kommen
Nice
Close
Geht mir hier eigentlich gerade was
B ist immer noch umkämpft
Wo ist denn B überhaupt
Wo ist denn B
Da
Ah ok
Wie man es überhaupt nicht richtig erkennt
Wir haben echt miese Positions gerade
Muss man mal sagen
Ich seh keine Gegner
Aber die sehen mich die ganze Zeit
Shit
Ok ich hol dich
Ich mach einfach Medic Points
Solange ich keine Gegner killen kann ist auch ok
Machen wir Punkte mit
Mit Heal
Die wissen halt dass wir da sind
Ich hab keine Ahnung wo die sind
Das was wir am besten können
Oh da war was ich hab es gesehen
Da oben war doch was oder
Leute ich bin manchmal nicht sicher ob ich
Boomer Augen Boomer Hirn hab oder so
Aber das war meiner
Keck wait
Hier kommt man nicht hoch
Boomer live
Ok und jetzt gehen wir
Jetzt gehen wir rüber zu
B
Ne hier gehen wir nicht lang
Hier schlägt mir schon eindeutig zu viel wieder ein
Granate
Smoke
Oh nice
Sind wir jetzt eigentlich in
Ah wir sind im Capture
Ok wir sind im Capture in diesem Kreis
Nicht sicher
Wo und was aber
Dead auf jeden Fall
Immer von der Seite
Wir waren mal Top Kills
Das hat sich erledigt
Gut wir haben aber auch Objective und Medic Stealth
Gespielt wäre das ja auch nicht unser Job
Zu haben
Äh
Hat man nicht V oder so
Hat man nicht irgendeinen Melee Angriff um
Um diese komischen Gitter kaputt zu machen
So
Jetzt wird es spannend
Wie kommen wir da rüber
Hier hat uns gerade eben was von der Seite gekillt
Ich probier es mal
Ach hier sind wir in diesem komischen Graben drinnen
Graben Stealth
Ok auf gehts
Ich mein hier sollten jetzt erstmal
Hier sind so viele von mir
Sollten jetzt erstmal keine Gegner sein
Aber man weiß
Da liegt einer
Da sind sie doch
Leute
Wo ist der hin
Man weiß es nicht
Ich mach jetzt das was ich ursprünglich machen wollte
Ist der Typ noch da
Wahrscheinlich
Ok so rüber an B
Vielleicht komm ich jetzt da hin
Wir haben jetzt gefühlt 3 Minuten lang
Nicht mehr am Game teilgenommen
Nein Game please
Sehr schön
Ich hasse es wenn so Jump Animationen im Game
Drinnen sind und die dann nicht funktionieren in dem Moment wo man sie braucht
Ist das einer von mir
Ach wir haben uns
Wir haben gewonnen oder
Easy win
Ohja wir haben die
1 eingefahren
Danke für den Sub
Es ist auch ein bisschen wie Hardcore
Von Frontline Experimental
Ok probieren wir mal Frontline aus
Die wollen nicht
Die wollen nicht spielen
Ok Leute was für eine Map
Das View kenne ich glaube ich noch nicht
Komm wir spielen mal was
Bei Nacht
Übrigens das Game hat
Ich bin nicht sicher ob das stimmt
18 Maps
Das mit 2042
Zu vergleichen
Weil so eine 2042 Map ist halt vom gestalterischen her
Viel aufwendiger
Als so Maps
Aber 18 Maps das ist mal eine ordentliche Anzahl
Ah das ist die Map
Mit der U-Bahn
Haben wir übrigens was neues bekommen
Ah AK-15
Und neue Unlocks
Magazine gibt es immer noch
Side Rail
Gab es da was
Brauche ich nicht
Barrel
Velocity
Moment Damage
Eigentlich ist das ein ziemlich guter Deal
Oder
Weil 0,6 Damage
Macht halt nichts
Aus
Das ist immer noch gleiche Anzahl
Time to kill
Schalldämpfer macht was
First Kickshot
Ich finde übrigens
Auf dem Maßstab denke ich
Dass Schalldämpfer nicht so geil sind
Weil man in dem Spiel ja kein Spotting
Und Minimaps hat
Der größte Vorteil vom Schalldämpfer
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht
Aber unsicher
Kann durchaus auch sein
Das es mega ist
Nach der Logik jetzt
Guck mal hier
Da fliegen die Maps
Die Cars über die Maps
Levolution
Ich weiß nicht genau wo der hin will
Aber Levolution
Und der Bus fliegt auch einfach weg
Das ist die U-Bahn
Da gehen wir nicht hin
Der U-Bahn Punkt sackt einfach nur extrem
Wir gehen zu F
Ich bleib mal ein bisschen im Auto
Hocken
Oh da kommt was
Achtung
Kann man das
Stealen
Das Auto von denen
Keine Ahnung
Ich brauch ein KS
Muss mich mal kurz healen
Was ist denn hier los
Schon wieder
Oh
Oh shit
Was ist hier los
Die Irren sind am Start
Übrigens das war krass
Das Pega Aim vom feinsten grad
F geht immer noch was ab
Wir gehen jetzt wieder zu F
In der Hoffnung
In der Hoffnung wir werden nicht von der Seite weg
Hallo
Hier
Wir nehmen jetzt einfach die Tür zu
Bling
Vorm Dach
F ist unseres
Auf dem Dach
Ich hab so ein bisschen meine Bedenken
Die kommt mir nicht
Der ist dead
Ich bin noch hier
Doktor
Teamplay Deluxe guckt euch das an
Jetzt kriegt ihr alle Kills
Sauerei
Ich heil dich
Wir machen jetzt Medik Points
Fuckin Shit
Nein
Die Mauer hat mich zerdrückt
Wir kommen jetzt am Start
Ok wo müssen wir denn jetzt
Überhaupt hin
Ich blick hier auf der Map nicht durch
Zu B
Ok zu B
Ne
Hier geht doch was gerade
Ich bin verwirrt
Wo ist denn hier was
Die Map bin ich noch nicht so
Da knowe ich noch nicht so auf der Map
Any knowers
Unter euch
Hier ist einiges los
Man sieht bloß nicht wo
Ok wir gehen mal Richtung
Hier ist irgendwas drinnen
Oh Shit
Shit
Der Suck alter
Hat er mich um flanked
Ich hab gedacht Leute
Da lohnt sich kein Ironsight mehr
Wir sprühen und
Sprühen und beten da einfach rein
Hier ist mir zu risikoreich
Warum ist hier alles zu
What the
Alter das ist ja wir
An jeder Ecke guckt hier irgendwie einer rum
Ok hier muss man sich
Hier muss man sich anstrengen Leute
Fivehead Modus aktivieren jetzt
Und Medic Points machen
Wir sind auf dem Dach
Das ist ne richtig
Fivehead Pog Position
Ist nicht die Pole Position ist die Pog Position
Ok auf die Range
Ist das Ding nix
Kannste klicken
Aber da ist doch was
Hier ist doch was oder
Ich geh mal hier runter
Vielleicht hab ich glücklich weg gerätst
Hier oben sind so viele Leute
No
Ich bleib trotzdem mal liegen
Vielleicht
Shit alter die sterben gerade alle auf dem Dach
Ok wir sind dead
Das ist schlecht
So wir müssen jetzt Fivehead Play machen Leute
Only Fivehead Plays
Ich kenn die Map nicht ich weiß nicht was wir hier gescheit machen können
Aber
Wir müssen irgendwie nen ordentlichen
Flank machen
So dass unser Team rein spawnen kann
Ich weiß aber nicht wohin
Richtung F
Vielleicht
Da ist F
Hier gehts nicht weiter
Hier gehts aufs Dach hoch
Weiß nicht
Au
Ich würde mich gerne heilen Game
Das ist aber gerade nicht erlaubt
Ok da gehen wir jetzt rein
Mal gucken ob wir
Alter Game nicht starten
Boah
Ok ist der jetzt despawned
Nein nein Game nicht da durchspringen
Ok
Das war schonmal ein guter Push
Exzellenter Push
Oben auf dem Dach
Oh das ist
Das ist gefährlich hier
WP geaimt
Ach die leben gar nicht mehr
Ok wisst ihr was YOLO
Ist mir egal Polle Polle
Die sind zu sehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt
Wir gehen jetzt rein
Und lasst uns von den Claymores ficken
Die wahrscheinlich hier rumliegen
Wo gehts denn hier überhaupt rauf
Alter lass mich dich
Aber die Zerstörung ist schon nice
Muss man sagen
Haben sie gut gemacht
Ich hab kaum noch Muni
Ich brauch mal einen mit Muni
Oder wie sie in Gears of War gesagt haben
Ich brauche Mun
Die Gears of War
Gears of War deutsche Übersetzung
Wie geht das mit Magazinen zusammenfassen
H drücken glaube ich
Ne
Ok keine Ahnung
AP
Ok das dauert zu lang Leute
Das dauert zu lang
Das PPGashit
Wo geht denn hier was
Ich höre total viele Gegner gerade
Oh oh oh
Hier über mir
Ne
Von wo
Was geht hier
Hier schießen 3000 Leute ich seh nichts
Oh oh
Nice
GG
Ich rette jetzt einfach mal
Nice
Good GG
Nice kill
Die Map verwirrt mich hoch gerade
Ich werde von
Von allen Ecken
Schossen und ich seh keine Gegner
Was ist das hier
Vielleicht sollten wir auch mal ein bisschen
Dachcampen
Und und und bisschen
Medicpoints machen
Guck mal die bedanken sich sogar
Hier wenn du geheilt wirst
Ok wir machen Dachcampen
Nice nice Dachcamper
Guck mal da
Guck mal da ist er
Mal gucken ob ich die nade treffe
Knapp knapp
Knapp knapp am Fenster
Wird das das man überhaupt hier nix
Predikten kann wie die Granaten fliegen
So wo geht denn hier jetzt gerade was
C C ist die U-Bahn Station da will ich nicht hin
F und E
C ist die U-Bahn
C Sack da geh ich nicht hin
Oh da
Habt ihr gesehen da sind ganz viele
Da waren ganz viele
Aber da sind bestimmt noch mehr
Wo
Wo Spiel wo
Alter
Wir sind wieder auf dem Dach
Kann man schon predikten ob das geht
Es ist anders es ist
Langsamer und taktischer
Als Battlefield das kann man
Denke ich sagen
Oh oh da unten ist gerade richtig
Was los
Von wo das war ja nicht der Typ
Da unten wer hat uns gerade auf dem Dach
Weggesprayed
F wo ist F F E
D C F
Da müssen wir hin
YOLO
Es geht gerade nix hier
Nice
Schön weggesprayed alles
Guck mal hier ist so open
Hier bist du eigentlich
Freiwillig
Bist du gefunden
Und ich weiß gar nicht wo ich hin soll
Wo ist denn F
Ach da oben ist F
Trau mich nicht so ganz
Gerade
Da ist nämlich der Pantsman der schießt hier alles kaputt
Shit
Bisschen zu früh aufgehört zu schießen
In Softcom Modus
Ich finde die Time to Kill
Geht
Ganz ehrlich das Hauptproblem ist das du nicht weißt
Von wo du beschossen wirst
Nicht so sehr die Time to Kill
Die Time to Kill ist eigentlich fine
Okay
Hier gehts aufs Dach ich geh jetzt nicht mehr aufs Dach
Dachcampen sackt
Gucken wir mal ob wir hier durchkommen
Aber jetzt ein paar mal sterben ist auch egal
Die Runde läuft eh nicht guckt euch das mal an
Keck wait
Ja
Es ist anders
Wie gesagt man kann das finde ich sogar
Vom Feeling her schlecht mit Battlefields
Vergleichen
Es hat so den Anstrich von Battlefield
Aber es spielt sich nicht wie Battlefield
Kann man hier jetzt rein
Oh nice
Ha
Wenn halt die Movement Mechanics
So funktionieren würden wie gedacht
Wär schon cool
Warum bist du in Combat
Ja der ist nicht in Combat
Ich hab so
Keine
So keine Orientation auf der Map
Shit
Oh oh
Ihr wisst das ich da bin oder
Ja der hat zweimal
Zweimal Headshot hat er gerade überlebt
Der Typ da
Was ist denn hier oben
Ist hier oben was
Ist hier was
Ich blicks nicht
Ist
Hier schlägt doch laufend was ein
Ne anscheinend
Anscheinend ist alles dead
Gehen wir mal Richtung F
Einfach mal
Aus dem fünften Stock gedroppt der Gude
Gehen wir mal
Oh da war was
Oder
Bin mir da nicht ganz sicher
Ja hier du kriegst von mir
Heal
Immer nice
Medik Points
Jetzt guck mal wie kaputt das alles ist
Du hast hier null Deckung
Du weißt überhaupt nicht wo du hin sollst
Vom Dach oder von wo werden wir beschossen
Zumindest ist stillstehen gefährlich
Was geht denn hier auf der Map
F C
Wie sehen eigentlich die Tickets aus
Gewinnen wir ich glaube wir gewinnen
Hier was
Ok auf gehts
Gib ihm
Charge
Ich will eigentlich sagen das sollen wir
Alter diese Map
Oder dieses Spotting System
What the fuck
Ich will spotten geht nicht
Du guckst drauf es verschwindet und du kannst es nicht spotten
Weird
F wo ist F
Ich seh die Dinger
Easy pass mal auf
Überlebe ich auch immer so
Ok gib ihm
Sind wieder hier
In der Hoffnung diesmal
Stellst uns keiner aus dem Fenster ab
Hier ist so kaputt
Jedes Straßen
Crossen ist dead
Ich weiß nicht
Von wo
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und können
Da ist einer
Ok pass mal auf
Wir jumpen jetzt hier unten rein
Fuck ich dachte hier ist ne Tür oder sowas
Flanken die
Shit
In dem Moment wo wir Flanken und
Fivehead Play machen
Da gehts richtig zur Sache
Manchmal verstehe ich die
Deads auch grad nicht
No
Nicht sterben
Du bist nicht in Combat
Ich seh doch du liegst da
Du kannst nicht in Combat sein
Der ist nicht in Combat
Jawohl
Medic Points
Alter bleib doch da
Ich farm einfach ein bisschen
Mit Gegner bashen klappt
Versteh ich grad nicht
Gucken ob wir irgendwelche
Nice Flank Plays machen können
Ok ok ok
Alter
Warum seid ihr alle tot immer
Ich seh
Oh
Der hats gekriegt
Richtig dicke
Ok
Flanken wir mal hier rüber
Hier oben ist doch was
Ne das sind meine Dudes
Was ist eigentlich grad der Plan
Richtung D
Oder
Textur für Wand und Boden
Alles gleich
Nicht vorhanden
Irgendwie haben wir den Gamefluss grad ein bisschen verloren
Sind immer an der falschen Stelle
Und gucken immer aus dem falschen Fenster
Ich höre hier einiges rumlaufen
Aber das sind wohl meine
Da war einer
Ja
Wir pushen anscheinend D
D Pusher
Da oben ist auf jeden Fall was
Ok vielleicht, vielleicht kriegen wir den
Bevor die Gegner um die Ecke kommen
Oh was
Hier geht richtig die Post ab nur dass ich nichts von mitbekomme
Oh
Schön den Kopf
Sag mal
Wie ist in dem Game der Headshot Multiplier
Der scheint mir teilweise extrem krass zu sein
Wow
Alter da sind 500 Gegner gegenüber
Oh da kommt ein L.A.V.
Wir pushen die grade richtig gut
L.A.V. down
Guck mal wir haben alle Flags gleich
Thank you
Pass mal auf hier sind doch Gegner noch
Oh schön texturierter Tunnel
Hier ist einfach zu viel grade
Wir haben hier einfach
Wir haben die komplette Map grade
Guck mal der kann sogar nur noch
In T-Pose rein spawnen bevor er dead ist
Äh
Hm
Wir haben gewonnen
Wir haben easy gewonnen und an uns lag es nicht
Wir haben nichts gerissen die Runde
Aber wir haben so easy gewonnen
Easy Clap
Äh was spielen wir? Infantry Conquest
Oder Domination
Fazit bis jetzt
Spielt sich besser
Als die ganzen Early Access
Pre oder Pre Early Access Playtests
Ohne dass ich jetzt so richtig
Mein Finger drauf legen kann was es ist
Ich muss mal sagen
Der Grafikstil ist immer noch
Nicht schön anzuschauen
Es gibt durchaus hübsche Pixelspiele
Ich spiele mal was anderes
Spielen wir mal das da
Gibt ja durchaus hübsche Pixelspiele
Aber
Bei dem hier fehlt einfach
Es sieht flach aus es fehlen Schatten
Es fehlen Details in den Maps
Was hat gewonnen? Welche Map?
Spielen wir? Tensortown
Hatten wir die heute schon mal?
Das mit Raytracing genau
Das habe ich auch schon ein paar mal gesagt
Ich könnte mir vorstellen mit Raytracing wäre das
Sehr sehr hübsch
Und nice
Haben wir ein bisschen was
Load Audit
Oh wir haben neue Unlocks
Jawoll Extended Map
Quick Reload
Das probiere ich mal aus
Camouflage
Haben wir eine neue?
Die hier Desert
Passt doch ganz gut
Underbarrel
Lassen wir einfach mal so
Gehts los?
Start In
Spawn mal hier in den komischen Fiat rein
Und ein Soundtrack
So ein bisschen minimalistischer
Soundtrack würde dem ganzen auch ganz gut
Tonen
Die Noobs fahren den Jeep
Ok Big Map
Irgendwelche Tipps ob wir ankommen?
Ich zweifle noch
Wir müssen eigentlich auch gar nicht zu E fahren
Oh Oh Oh Oh
Boom
So fahren wir D
D ist gut
Lets go
Ich steige aus
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr
Jetzt verschwindet D einfach wenn ich es markieren will
Wir spielen doch gleich mal eine Runde
Engineer
Leichter Stelzmodus aktiviert
Da drüben waren gerade 5 Gegner
Wir müssen langsam vorgehen
Sonst sind wir dead
Wow
Leute ich habe dem gerade 3 mal in den Kopf geschossen
Weißt du was das Game gemacht wurde?
Unreal
Ich glaube Unreal
Ich glaube was gelesen zu haben
Könnte aber genauso gut Unity sein
Ich glaube ich habe was gelesen
Zu Unreal
Ich glaube ich habe Unreal gelesen
Ist gut
Lass mich in Ruhe
Jetzt sind wir an D ran
Geh nochmal hier außen rum
Leute wisst ihr was mich das erinnert?
Das ist wie an die eine Modern Warfare 2
Kampagnen Map
Wo man mit dem LLV durch die Häuser fährt
Erinnert sich da noch jemand dran?
Modern Warfare 2 Kampagne LLV
Wo man den LLV begleiten muss
Achtung da kommen gleich noch ein bisschen mehr
Membert noch irgendjemand?
Das ganze
Newtown
Nicht alles mit Häusern sieht aus wie Newtown
Nein
Oh das war close
Vielleicht habe ich Glück
Yolo Rats
Ich muss mich verpissen
Können wir vielleicht von hinten flanken?
In den S
Nicer Flank haben wir gut gemacht
Oh
Shit Alter
Ich habe gerade Reload
Warum habe ich Released?
Ne die Leute sind
Die changen es nicht
Leute hier waren gerade 50 Gegner
50 Teammates wo seid ihr alle hin?
Wir hatten es doch gerade so easy
So easy
Okay wo ist D?
D
Da sind Gegner
PP Gas sind da
Jede Menge kleiner PP Gas
Wie?
Nice alle dead
Dead
Wow
Leute
Da war doch niemand gerade
Das ist
Frontal von vorne gekommen gerade
Da war niemand
Wo kam das her?
Ich checke es in dem Spiel einfach oftmals nicht
Von wo was kommt
Wir hauen da einfach mal
Ne Granate rein
Vielleicht können wir ein bisschen
Flankerino machen
Da guck mal da kann man aufs Dach?
Ne kann man nicht
Ist ja schlimmer wie in Battlefield 3
Halt's Maul
Ich war fast verreckt
Wegen dem Dude
Okay wir probieren jetzt mal hier den da
Alter Mann
Immer irgendein Dude der hinguckt
Ich weiß das man ziehen kann
Aber ich war mitten im Rats
War ja eigentlich eine gute Posi
Und dann kam halt ein Gegner
Spawnen
Okay wir gehen hier hin
Da
Kann ich da hin?
Sind hier Drops aktiv?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal wie man drops
Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendwelche
Absprachen mit dem Hersteller
Sag mal
Können die heute auch mal umfallen wieder?
Please
What the fuck
Okay ich
Toxic AF
Wollte gerade rüber switchen zur Pistol
Weil ich immer genug Schuss hab
Oh hier haben wir was
Hier kommt einer mit nem Panzer an
Let's go
Wow
Ey dieses Game Alter
Du bist immer von der Seite weggefickt
Immer da wo du nicht hin willst
Das haben sie sich von Battlefield abgeguckt
Okay ich muss die wirklich tracken
Was ist das? F gell
F muss man drücken um die zu schleifen
Oder E?
Nee ich glaub F
Alter wir sacken mal so krass rein in die Runde
Wo können wir denn hin?
E?
Warum verschwindet das denn?
C?
F? Wo geht denn hier was?
Eigentlich können wir nur realistisch betrachtet C
Da war doch was oder?
Okay flank
Flanken
Direkt
Direkt drauf rennen ist dead
Absolut keine Ahnung von wo
Aber gut
Haus stellts
Nix da
Hä? War das jetzt gerade ein Gegner?
Alter
Switch halt auf die Waffe man
Wenn man 1 drückt
Langsam regts mich auf
Guck mal wenn man auf medikit ist
Drückt 1
Drückt 1 nur jetzt funktioniert es
Jetzt geht das
Schon Rush gespielt? Ja Rush ist komisch
Hier sind doch einige
Drinnen
Ich heile euch mal ein bisschen
Habt ihr keinen Bock? Okay
Das sind alles meine Leute
C
Wir verlieren knapp
Rush auf C
Ja
Hab ich schon
Wir sind dead wahrscheinlich
Gleich
Ja nice von hinten das Auto
Alles klar was sonst
Das macht gerade echt
Keinen Spaß
Wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin?
Ich meine es ist eigentlich C
Es ist immer C
Scheiß drauf
Wir gehen jetzt A
Fühlt sich das Movement block
Das Movement fühlt sich teilweise ein bisschen auf Rädern an
Von was zum
Es hat überhaupt nichts auf mich geschossen
Aber es hört sich so an
Was ist das denn?
Ist das ein Spawn Beacon
Von den Gegnern?
Alter wie viel hält denn das Ding aus?
Ich höre Wasser
Man hat hier keine Schusslinie aus dem Fenster
Na geil
Nice Game danke
Perfekt
Der erwischt mich jetzt eh gleich
Während ich mich heile
Wie zum Teufel stirbt der nicht
Leute ich hab 10 Stück dem Ding gerade in den Kopf geballert
Wie zum Teufel
Ist der nicht gestorben
Ich hab sogar schon aufgehört zu schießen
Weil ich mir gedacht okay der ist jetzt down
Bling bling bling bling
Fuck
Was soll man denn noch so machen außer drauf schießen
Jetzt heile ich den mal aus gerade
Okay nice
Er ist tot
Plus 200
Wie das heißt ich hab ihm doppelt sein Leben
Gewünscht gemacht oder wie
Was? Okay da sind noch mehr hier
Vielleicht
Ah nice
Irgendwas ist hier
Ich weiß bloß nicht so genau wo
Okay reviven ist
Nicht gewünscht
Ich hab gedacht was macht der da in der Ecke
Die kommen gleich noch mehr
Leute ich sags euch
Ich camp mich jetzt unter die Brücke
Oder unter die Treppe
Wir sind nämlich direkt an C dran
Wollte ich nicht hin
Hier ist noch
MonkaS
Der wusste natürlich das ich da bin
Der ist ja nicht blöd
Das hat man jetzt ja auch weit genug gesehen
Spawn
C
Hier da gehen wir auf jeden Fall nicht lang
Die
Das ist einer von uns okay
Ich hab seriously keine Ahnung von wo
Was okay das war
Das war PPGuard
Das war glaube ich einfach ein Pixel vorbei
Hat das SBMM oder was
Warum sind hier alle so
Also spawnpoint
Donation
Nee Donation wozu
Behalt deine Kohle
Ist da was
Das ist auch so ein Punkt
Die
Häuser sind
Irgendwie so komisch
Warum ist hier kein Durchgang
Ich hab mal einen Link
Ich hatte mal was gemacht aber
Das hab ich seit 3 Jahren nicht mehr drin
Okay
Wo sind wir jetzt
C
Meine Leute gehen zu A
Wo ist A
Wo
Das soll man jetzt erkennen oder was
Dass da A ist
Überlebt
Müssen wir mal kurz ins Haus
Sonst sind wir dead
Nicht gesehen
Nimm C4
Ich hab kein C4 auf dem Medic
Und meine Leute sind auch tot
Kann man Super Chat
Deaktivieren
Leider nicht
Man kann das auf 100 Euro oder so hochstellen
Dann macht es keiner
Okay Leute mir reicht es für heute
Kein Bock mehr
Ich merk das auch
Ich spiel dann überhaupt nicht mehr fokussiert
Wenn es mir anfängt auf den Sack zu gehen
Boomer hier und kann das nicht mehr
Normalerweise hätte ich jetzt
Ja gesagt wir spielen noch eine Runde Rush XL
Aber es ist schon Bedgetime
Amazing
Danke für den Sub
Komm einmal gucken wir rein
EA
Sekunde
Ich seh Super Chat überhaupt nicht
Guck mir das gar nicht an
Ich muss kurz bei EA einloggen
Hat es das jetzt endlich
Okay nice
So eine Runde
Eine Runde Rush XL
XXXL
Weil ich einfach
Ich will wissen ob es was taugt
Also wahrscheinlich nicht
Du wirst es hassen glaube ich auch
Wahrscheinlich spiel ich 2 Sekunden
Und dann bin ich weg
Düdüdüdüdüdüdü
Passende Menümusik
Rusch
XL
128 Spieler Rush auf diesen Maps
Das kann nicht funktionieren
Das klappt nicht
Im Leben nicht
Das wird so satten
Ist für 15 Euro im Angebot
Ja für den gleichen Preis kannst du auch Battle Bit kaufen
Ich glaube das hat größere Zukunft
Was ist da im Hintergrund los
Orbital
Die ist ja schon mit 32 Spielern
Was zum
Ich check überhaupt nicht
Das Gameswitchen ist wir
128 Spieler
Auf der Map
Alter was ein Bullshit
Was haben sie sich damit ausgedacht
Okay nice
Man sieht übrigens dass die Sachen hier
Battle Bit
Aber Battle Bit fixen sie es wenigstens noch
Du kannst hier nicht mal raus
Sobald ich meinen Kopf raus strecke
Bin ich dead
Es gucken gerade doppelt so viele Spieler in meine Richtung
Wie sonst
Und guck mal hinter dem Fels ist immer mehr genug Platz
Für alle Spieler
Okay
Pega Modus
X Deluxe
Was ein Scheiß
Was
Was ein Schwachsinn
Alter wer hat sich das
Ausgedacht
Der normale Rush ist ja schon
PP gar
Das ist gar kein Gegner
Guck mal das Game kommt überhaupt nicht mehr mit
Game
Was ein Schwachsinn
Das ist einfach nur bescheuert
Ich mein die Sachen haben sich
Erika Haber würde ich
Beispielsweise mal ganz gerne spielen damit
Gucken ob das gut funktioniert
Das ist wirklich
Richtiger Suma Spielmodus
Ich würde übrigens gerne woanders spawnen
Als bei meinen Leuten
580 Tickets auch noch
Du kannst ja eigentlich
Als Defender
Gar nicht gewinnen
Auf den Maps mit so vielen Tickets
Die haben einfach die Spieleranzahl
Verdoppelt und die Ticket Anzahl
Verfünffacht
Battlefield Logik
Okay du kannst eigentlich im Prinzip
Was ein
Bullshit Alter
Irgendjemand bei DICE hat sich
Gedacht
Das ist eine gute Idee
Ich weiß nicht wer
Wahrscheinlich der gleiche der sich
Spezialist ausgedacht hat oder sowas
Okay wir haben verloren
Die Runde wahrscheinlich
Aber die Ticket Anzahl
Guckt euch das mal an die Ticket Anzahl ist viel viel
Zu hoch
Die haben sich gedacht
Jetzt ist es auch egal
Okay
Wahrscheinlich haben sie sich das gedacht
Jetzt ist auch alles wurscht
Machen wir mal irgendwas
Rein wo vielleicht ein paar Leute noch reinkommen
Ins Spiel ein paar Microtransactions kaufen
Doser
Wenn ich den Held schon sehe
Krieg ich schon Ausschlag
Guck mal da ist er
Keiner kriegt den gekillt
Guckt euch das Elend an
Dann spiel ich ja tatsächlich lieber
Battlebit
Jetzt ohne Miss
Das war zwar wir gerade komplett
Das Game hat auch nicht richtig funktioniert an vielen Stellen
Aber ich mein
Man sieht zumindest das sie sich was gedacht haben
Dabei und hier siehst du eigentlich nur
Das sie ihr eigenes Game nicht verstehen
Ich mein auf diesen Maps
What the
Das ist ja teilweise schon mit 32 problematisch
Guckt euch das
Elend an man
Guckt euch das Elend an
Das ist wirklich der
Der Suma Mode für Battlefield 2042
Die sehen mich nicht
Lul
Pass auf die kommen jetzt hier gleich
Die werden jetzt gebashed wenn sie hier durchkommen
Ja das ist schon der erste
Irgendwo hier
Was ist denn das
Wer hat sich bei Dice gedacht
Das ist das ist the way Rush zu spielen
Hypers
Pepega
Pepega Deluxe quasi
Okay das war Pepega Aim
Vielleicht kriege ich einen Rest
Ich mein hier sind immerhin Leute gerade am Start
Oh ist sie weg
Das nächste Battlefield soll ja
2024 kommen
Ich liege eigentlich
Relativ safe
Ihr könntet mich holen wenn ihr Bock habt
Aber die haben glaube ich keinen Bock
Oh doch da kommt was
Pssst
Okay
Ja
Trollt er mich
Er hat mich gebashed
Ich weiß nicht worauf ich da
Eigentlich gerade schieße
Okay ich habe zwei gekillt es war
Komplett calculated
Ich wollte die killen
Guckt euch mal den
Guckt euch den Felsen an
Okay wie gesagt letzte
Erste und letzte Runde heute
Okay Kills
Für Kills Farmen ist das okay
Aber Kills Farmen kannst du auch zum unlocken
Einfach mit der
Okay pass mal auf
Im Bot Modus
Im Bot Modus kannst du es ja auch machen
Wenn du aber die Kills Farmen willst
Ich meine ich werfe
Mich mal ein bisschen rein
Wir haben eh unendlich Tickets als Defender
Also
Eigentlich egal
Guckt euch das an
Ich habe einfach keine
Respawn Zeit
Nicht mal Respawn Time
Du kannst einfach Instant Respawn
Als Defender sehr gute Idee
Auch von DICE Instant Respawn
Als Defense
Exzellente Idee Leute
Exquisite
High IQ
Wir gewinnen das anscheinend doch
Ich pushe einfach rein
Wir haben unendlich Tickets
Guckt euch das Elend an
Er ist wirklich hängen geblieben
Das kann ich nicht mehr als eine Runde spielen
Normaler Rush ist schon fragwürdig
Aber das
Thermal für Smokes
Okay
Das mag hier wirklich der
High IQ Move sein
Thermal für Smokes
Ich glaube aber die ACR hat gar kein Thermal
Aber wir können
Wir können eine Waffe mit Thermal
Komm das machen wir jetzt
Ich glaube ich habe in dem Game noch nie Thermal gespielt
Welche Waffe hat denn hier überhaupt Thermal
Keg W6
Die da hat bestimmt Thermal
Äh
Thermal jawohl
Let's go
Äh
Moment
Au
Äh Thermal suckt
Aber die Idee war gut Chat
Okay
Äh
Ich spiel das ohne Thermal
Gleich ist fertig
25 Tickets noch
Absoluter Papega Modus
Ich mein
Wir haben es uns angeguckt okay
Das muss reichen
Okay nice gg
Reicht echt jetzt
Äh Thermal Visier für Heli
Keine Ahnung ich spiel normalerweise keine Helis
Warte mal kurz zur Entspannung
Oh
Morgen spielen wir noch ein bisschen Battle Bit
Ich muss noch ein bisschen spielen
Dass ich mal im Video qualifiziert was zu sagen kann
Und ich brauch auch ein bisschen
Gameplay für den Hintergrund
Ich mein ich kann irgendwas aus dem Stream zusammenschneiden
Aber wäre schon cool wenn man noch ein bisschen mehr hätte
Oh Schneiber
Plus nicht
Machs gut Leute
Wo ist eigentlich der Sebaro
Jetzt wo ich den Namen gerade
So einen ähnlichen Namen sehe
Rust one on one intervention only
Ja auf gehts
Ich installier mal schnell MW2019
Nee oder welche
Wo gab es Rust
Nee doch gab es doch MW2019
Oder hatten sie doch auch irgendwann Rust drinne
Ich geb dir Hater auf Rust
Okay bis morgen Leute
Wir sehen uns 10 Uhr